what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Hufford and I'm back we're
gonna watch Game of Thrones episode two
before we hop into this did want to
reiterate again that for YouTube were
only allowed to show ten minutes of
footage so there's only gonna be
reaction highlights for this one and
this is being edited by our good friend
Eric over at nerd cronic whose work you
can see edited through like Iman snow al
qassam he's done a lot of work on the
Schmo down you can go check out his
YouTube videos and podcasts at nerd
chronic wherever podcasts are actually
found and also we're gonna be doing our
full-length reaction stream along for
this entire episode and for all the Game
of Thrones for our patreon page and over
at our patreon page we actually do a TV
show reaction stream along for many
shows that includes my hero academia
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man supernatural
Gotham Jon did all haunting of Hill
House and several of those shows also
have reaction highlights included that
includes one punch man my hero academia
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood and
supernatural and so yeah anyhow let's
get into this game of Thrones
shenanigans now shall we she did don't
see you know me I see one man with one
hand he attacked my father in the
streets he tried to destroy my house and
my family the same as he did yours
apologize they're teaming up okay
everything I did I did for my house and
my family I did all again the things we
do for love
ransom like this you don't know me well
yeah she's finally gonna speak Chinese
to Jamie he is a man honor you would
fight beside him I would
Wow we just we just heard all the
Jamie's holes character are just Jamie's
so gonna die this season so much he knew
he knew she was one he's got many faces
hmm
i sprung out stand here anymore take the
day off
oh no he was like turned on oh she can
throw the knife she could definitely
kill me you won't be able to help us in
this face like that the murder you first
what about happened once how do you know
that isn't after
where the end game now but Syrian
mustard really happen to have Jamie
there if he is on Terry does look like
he's happened I think this seems pretty
pissed about the whole Cersei thing but
at least he's got his brother but
actually we have like I've been using my
it's correct that's how we feel about
job the fight I used to be deserving to
you come on Oh
it's like saying he loved did you think
I'll make nice wasanta
ladies not so I was hoping we could
speak of them no just guys here's
everything I love her like chain neck
thing see and I'm in love with Ethan
arias like hold like we've both done a
damn good job of it from what I can tell
oh man do stupid things for women easily
manipulated Amen sister my life I've no
wonder now a mere half the world away
fighting John's war alongside him tell
me who manipulated who did I was
manipulating every said we've never
bowed to anyone else again what about
the north
don't pull your hand away I want to [ __ ]
the wind fair lady sunset you gonna die
I know he's gonna die
[Music]
Oh
people really care about each other in
the North Daenerys is like what that
people really feel for each other you
know oh wow wonder there's only six
episodes of season for me he's tried
before many times have many throws
reasons why nobody died hey hey
brand-new I'd died next to me
oh it could be yes I'm glad you're here
he bites you glad you survived Eastwatch
they call me Giantsbane
want to know why say yes
IQ the giant wins
tender right with his wife why do second
man to date for three months Soto was
his baby that seven got some strong glad
this should not end here whole scene was
my favorite so far in the season you got
to see us Foreman flirts you know I used
to shut up now you're just sitting there
like a muse
because I've changed
we fall for you do my Robert Baratheon's
Buster's I didn't know until she told me
she tied me up stripped me down over me
that was a good episode soon oh oh oh
now I mean yes I are we going to see her
naked and no take it oh maybe that's
nice what now there's gonna be one of
these every episode women copy nights
why not
tradition so tradition tip huh oh yeah
being nice I'm no king but is over by
tonight you ten times oh it's so sweet
Assam tea any night can make another
night
in the name of the warrior the charge is
to be brave
the name of the father the charger to be
just
the name mother
let's not you to defend the innocent
[Music]
arise Princeton
the night facilitators
got a little - does it die
[Music]
[Music]
respect a wheeled it in his memory to
guard the realms of men
I'll see you in these I hope they do
stop it on my RV I know I like whoo boy
it's gonna add with them just showed up
right remember wanted never wanted to
leave never wanted
[Music]
Jesus Christ God everyone told me he was
decent and kind and he raped her he
loved her the race as is busted my name
you think I'm talking
[Music]
if it were true it would make you the
last male you'd have plenty
[Music]
oh no they're here Oh Oh Lord
uh-huh I have a theory a battle Oh No
she's terrible timing I told you
there it is
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I half expected to see the ice
dragon and then let's talk about this
episode guys all right guys we're gonna
talk about Game of Thrones this episode
right now for we go into that it is
April and it's Autism Awareness Month
Olivia works with autistic children so I
asked her if she could actually say
something about that because I feel like
more people should be aware Olivia
please since you work with autistic
children help the viewers become more
aware aware this month so basically just
light it up blue if you could change
your profile pictures to blue do some
research on autism autism Speaks is a
good organization that does a lot of
research also asam which is autism
self-advocacy Network which is a
non-profit group run by people who are
on the spectrum so if you go there do
little research
donate to them it's that's a really
great nonprofit organization light it up
blue I'd want to change the stigma about
autism Thank You Olivia
well since you already just spoke there
what do you think of this episode I
loved this episode I think it might be
one of my favorite game of Thrones
episodes of all time John I had a great
time too I mean I'm just I love the
build-up that they're giving us for the
major battles to come and I like that
these first two episodes have been very
much about context and character stuff I
think that what they've been doing here
is brilliant because I feel like they
have shaped these six episodes to be the
format of a movie but to just really be
expanded upon like the first episode is
a reintroduction a lot of people have
done their recaps and whatnot but a lot
of people also haven't so they had to do
sort of a reintroduction to where our
characters have been what the setup is
here you're settling in with them before
the battles begin both like that like
we're gonna get that big battle next
week but you know it's gonna be more
than just this one battle but at the
same time I love how they're not wasting
any time like the first episode you know
it's like Danny and John show from
brands like they got your dragon and
James Sam you need to have a talk with
John and then this
he's like they're gonna be here before
morning well I felt like a lot really
went down in this episode and I loved
the interactions with everyone because
it was more than just a reintroduction
reset up there was that sort of
nostalgic feeling is a lot of this
episode had a theme of remember how far
we've come remember where we've all come
from and how much we've changed over
yeah especially with Jamie cuz my
favorite the whole scene out of this
episode I mean Jamie is like one of the
main highlights of it but my favorite
scene is when Tyrion and Jamie are
drinking by the fires and everyone
starts slowly showing up without one
Roman again warm when Brendan gets
knighted that was [ __ ] cried so much
early seasons of Game of Thrones too so
I feel like that moment in general just
harkens back to the classic game well
yeah cuz when we first met her that was
such a big motive for her in her journey
has changed so much with a lot of these
characters getting sort of like
emotional resolutions before this battle
begins it puts that fear in you that
worried but like which one of these
people is gonna die cuz it seems like
you're setting up all these people to
die right now which is concerning
because then you're like well drawers
are cos wrapped up Brienne sarkis behind
of Theon these are people who are highly
likely to die yeah and I actually for
some reason my mind didn't register just
how much of a conflict it would be for
Jamie to show up at Winterfell it's
because so much has happened and then
when they're talking about they get it
pretty much summed up all the Jamie's
story in that one one trial right there
like here all the horrible things you
did and then Brienne steps in and goes
here's all the great things that he's
become because of all that even having
that resolution with bran having that
sort of awkward conversation that he
needed to have I thought was really neat
because at first it seems like brands
kind of giving him the cold shoulder you
know like Brad's got some issues with
the guy but even Brad says like you
needed to push me out of that window in
order for you to become who you haven't
become so far it just really seems like
Jamie's on his way to die hell I called
him Jamie's the one who died next
episode but I think it's obvious he's
going to die in this season I feel like
that's obvious
now you spin off I'm talking about a
whole new Jamie series after
this I love the dynamic yeah between
tormund and Brienne and then you have
Jaime and Brienne yeah I don't feel I
feel like some people might you know
ship Jaime and Brienne III don't read
the books
how it goes in the book so there's lots
of [ __ ] I feel like the dynamic they've
established is very different though
here I feel like there's like a a
trinkle of that but there's just a lot
of like respect yeah yeah I would love
for torment to actually get pretty mind
it I think it makes more sense is the
moment where United her I feel like that
was symbolic enough in the moment
exactly they have honor sex I love it I
love how we got to get more Tyrion in
this episode too and you know it was
your theory would Tyrion because I feel
like he's a good guy Tyrion gonna betray
Danny and I think so I a hundred percent
do I think he'll die Lannister his whole
theme and I think they've set it up
really if you pay really close attention
to the episodes I think they've set it
up to it that's my theory
we'll see how it plays out but I think
in the end he'll betray Danny and it'll
come out that he knew that seriously
what her plan was I hate that and they
see like where's the first episode of
this season sort of felt like sort of
soap opera elements the drama for me
really hit here like this to me was like
yeah this is vintage Game of Thrones
you're emotionally involved could you
care so much yeah cuz the first episode
kind of moved really fast and then this
one really took its time a lot more with
settling into these of moments here I
mean Aria and Gendry Oh God
I mean they we were all like yeah oh
good you're gonna hook up right oh yeah
we got six episodes let's get to the
city
they know they're not wasting any time
with anything then in the back of your
mind you're like oh but that's interrupt
wickley so that means what does that
mean now one of those totally right I
don't know they're gonna have a sex
scene in every subsequent thing I don't
know if that was a good idea I mean
though weakens the knees man gingery
doing it before going into battle like I
don't know that you're gonna that
eventually cause like the battle is just
about yeah it's like you kind of need
that tension in your body I don't think
we're leaving it was such a good idea I
know you only live once the vice before
you go into a fight people do not do it
uncomfortable conversations with Danny
in this episode - I thought she was
great in this episode yeah I did too I
prefer her no Olivia oh my god Danny oh
no do you think what is gonna happen
what's gonna happen good thought it
takes okay
I don't like Danny that's evidence I
still don't like her but I am glad that
they are are making her a little smart I
think at the end she's gonna become the
mad queen honestly I think that's where
this is headed - feels like they're
building it up - I think that's the
second the second John told her what was
up it was first thought wasn't like we
shouldn't be doing it first thought was
wait a minute you could get the identity
and what she's been raised to is to get
the Iron Throne that is her whole
identity I understand why she goes to
that but I also can see twisting into
this like driving her mad well it's
because they had this setup there with
her a conversation would Sansa how she's
saying like my love for John is what
brought me here yeah beyond that though
it's like that love for John is probably
gonna do endl down a hell of a lot
knowing a you're actually my nephew and
and also I don't think John's gonna die
in the next episode now but I think
there's gonna be a moment where I'm shot
in my theory that I was thinking was
John's gonna there's gonna be a moment
where Danny's gonna have a conflict of I
could let John die right he
I don't know what its gonna be maybe she
has her dragons or she could save him
there's gonna be something where she's
gonna be at a real conflict of I could
let him die and you see that but she
ultimately doesn't let him die or
something
but John still survives John Snow what
she said today I
I think it would be really cool if I
like to me personally I it doesn't make
me hate Daenerys if she becomes the mad
queen I think that'd be a really cool
plot point
that'd be a great plot point if she does
end up becoming like you know oh god
you've you've done it you've evolved
into it yeah you know here ian has to
kill her and then he's the queen Slayer
and the Jaime's the King Slayer there
you go everyone's a Slayer I liked her
more this episode because they played
her to be smart where she is
wait what's going on with Tyrion this
doesn't make sense and they shouldn't
have a lot of just logical choices on
everything and I did like that her first
response to the John thing is her throne
it makes sense to me because that's her
entire identity I also really liked the
scene with her and Sansa you like you
know they're not gonna like they keep
teetering on they make friendship happen
nah it ain't gonna happen cuz those are
some great debates to really think about
afterwards and know Cersei this episode
and I feeling we probably won't check in
with Cersei so maybe the fourth episode
after the white Walker bath cuz it's
like you got to wrap up everything with
the white walkers and then you got to
wrap up everything with Cersei in these
next few episodes only four more to go
do you want to talk about ghosts yes who
is the star of the show I feel like
maggots and ghosts are clearly the stars
you notice we don't see any dragons this
episode because the CGI budget went to
ghosts I don't know what's gonna happen
next if so we might not see ghosts are
we gonna see the Dragons episode this
was a great episode ever I'm really
looking forward to what happens next
week that's gonna be an end to the hour
and a half hours I think
yeah gone next episode Jaime Tyrion Dani
and Jonah No
or they're gonna be like all bets are
off I think beyond like you could say
gray warm but you need someone who's a
little bit more up there as a more main
character because Theon thought one of
the main characters but he's one of the
main characters so you know what I mean
he's like second tier main here and I
think you need a death like just
thinking riding wise you need a death
like that you're gonna get at least two
deaths next week and grey worm and fian
will be gone next week and I feel like
you gotta kill off at least one just
like major [ __ ] I think Torres gone next
week
you think Jorah as well Torres gone I
think Patrick's gone oh I think really
not for anyway yeah Breanna's gone
Brienne I think I could see it's like
instead I could see Brienne dying before
Podrick they wrapped up this [ __ ] whole
arc this episode and they wrapped it up
she got exactly what she wanted
I get to bang any of them I hope they
don't kill Jordan I'm really hoping he's
the last one best one we got right now
I'm hoping obviously no dragons are
ghosts I will flip this I think it was
gonna be some harrowing deaths because
they keep talking they keep setting up
that it's safe in the crypt and I just
oh oh something's in the girl that's
they're gonna do they're gonna kill all
the kids you can raise the dead all of
the stark family is buried in the crypts
right I'm just gonna say you can raise
that would be crazy cuz I was think
about that during the episode yes you're
just gonna hide among your own dead
exactly don't you have to you don't have
to be killed by a night Walker though
you know you could just like go to a
graveyard and raise people think you can
write you know I'd have to brush up on
the rules of how White's work but I
think you can bring back and then White
Walkers control like the ones they
brought back kind of like Voodoo's oh
yeah well guys who do you think's what
do you think's gonna happen next week
leave it in the comments below and
shouts out to Rosa Parra from the
patreon patron of the day who have given
us these mugs from a long time ago she
is the lady stork of our channel John
grab all the pot figures
all these awesome pop figures given her
stamper ago over there
Ron who is not in this episode pound
County area are you oh god Jamie and
mine
okay Rosa we we love you Rosa thank you
so much everything even when this show
was done you will still be considered
the lady stark of our Channel yeah also
shouts out to your daughter Cassandra
because I know she prefers me over John
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell
follow Olivia forever Tiffany's autism
awareness month go go find an autism kid
on the street even the dollar that's not
how it works check out our patreon page
full links move along over there thank
you Eric nerd chronic for editing the
video much love thanks buddy